[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAWN LEE TU: I'm really
excited to be here
with you this afternoon,
because the folks
on this panel, such a wealth
of experience and knowledge.
And I know they're
going to give you
tons of things to take
away with you after you
leave this afternoon.
I have the privilege of
facilitating this panel,
and you know what?
We're just going to
dive straight in.
So let's start off
with an easy question.
All right.
Let's start off with
an introduction.
Tell us a little bit about
yourself, what you do,
and what issue, in your
opinion, is impacting
Asians and Asian-Americans that
really matters to you right
now.
So introductions and
what issue that's
impacting Asians
and Asian-Americans
that's really important and
matters to you right now.
AIMEE PHAN: My
name is Aimee Phan.
I am a fiction writer.
I've written two
works of fiction.
The first is a collection of
stories called "We Should Never
Meet," which deals with the--
there are eight
stories surrounding
the events of Operation
Baby Lift, which
was the emergency
evacuation of Amerasians
and Vietnamese orphans days
before the Vietnam War.
And my second book
is a novel called
"The Reeducation
of Cherry Truong,"
and it's about a
multi-generational Vietnamese
family living in both
France and America.
And so from both of those
books, and most of my work
has been dealing with
stories about people
from the Vietnamese diaspora.
So my books are often
taught in college campuses
and even high school campuses.
And the issues
that often come up
when I have these
discussions with them
is about immigration
and refugee experiences
and how people migrate
around the world
and deal with the different
social, political, and cultural
communities that
arise from history
and what we can learn from them.
And so I feel like that probably
is the most important issue
that pops up in a lot of
my readings and panels
and discussion is how do we
address the current immigration
and the ongoing
immigration issues that
are happening, not only in this
country, but around the world?
How do we help other people
and other countries in need?
And I think, especially the
Vietnamese community, we
have a lot to say about it,
especially since our community
was the last major migration
of refugees into America.
We haven't had
another recent one,
and I think that the
Vietnamese-American community
can be seen as an example
of the incredible benefits
and richness that can
happen when you are generous
and when you are
compassionate and when
you're exercising empathy, which
is I think something that's
really important to
consider when we're thinking
about a lot of laws that are
being enacted and proposed
right now.
DAWN LEE TU: Thank you, Aimee.
ANOOP PRASAD: So
my answer, I think,
ties into that quite a bit.
My name is Anoop Prasad.
I'm a staff attorney in the
Immigrant Rights Program
at the Asian Law Caucus.
The Asian Law Caucus is the
civil rights organization
in San Francisco.
We've been around since 1972.
My work is largely
representing immigrants
who are facing deportation.
And my client base is largely
southeast Asian refugees--
Vietnamese, Cambodian,
Hmong, [INAUDIBLE],,
Mien refugees who came
here in the '70s and '80s
and are now facing
deportation, largely
for criminal convictions.
And the experience is
really common across a lot
of these refugee communities
of resettlement in the US,
where the resettlement
process was really flawed.
They were resettled
in neighborhoods
that had really high
rates of poverty,
high rates of unemployment,
high rates of incarceration,
at the height of
the war on drugs.
And a lot of them were funneled
into the prison system,
the criminal system,
when they were teenagers
and now decades later
are facing deportation.
And it's become a
particular issue and problem
as the Trump administration
has cracked down,
especially on Vietnamese
and Cambodian communities,
with deportation raids.
And it's one of
those issues which
gets overlooked a lot in
a lot of the narratives
around Asian experience.
DAWN LEE TU: Thank you.
RUSSELL JEUNG: Hi, everybody.
My name is Russell Jeung.
I'm Chair of Asian-American
Studies at San Francisco State.
We're celebrating our 50th
anniversary of the Third World
Strike and the founding
of Asian-American Studies.
I've been living for
the last three decades
in a low-income Asian-American
community in Oakland.
And there, I think I see
a lot of pressing issues
facing low-income and
working-class Asian-Americans.
And if you talk about--
you're not supposed to talk
about an oppression Olympics,
but I do think that people
living on the margin,
living on the edge, do
face a lot more struggle
and suffering.
And so I have a lot
of unhoused neighbors
who are Asian-American.
I actually have students
at San Francisco State who
are in Asian-American cities,
majoring in Asian-American
Cities, living in their cars.
And so issues of class and
intersectionality with race
and immigration
and gender I think
are really pressing
for our time,
that a lot of the Asian-American
community isn't aware of.
Besides homelessness,
on a broader scale,
we're having mass displacement
of Asian-American communities.
You can see Chinatowns
disappearing.
You see a lot of gentrification
in low-income Asian-American
communities.
So I find that
really significant.
DAWN LEE TU: Thank you.
CHRISTINE MINJI
CHANG: Hi, everyone.
My name is Minji Chang, and I'm
the former Executive Director,
now Board Member
of Collaboration.
And Collaboration is a
nonprofit organization
and a grassroots movement
to unify, discover, connect,
elevate Asian-American,
Pacific-Islander artists.
So we deal with artists,
musicians, dancers, comedians,
filmmakers, actors.
I'm also an actor, now
writer, podcast host, emcee,
et cetera, multi-millennial.
That is my representation
on this panel.
And the most pressing issue
that I'm interested in
is definitely
diversity in Hollywood.
That is my entire universe,
especially Asian-American
representation, working within
and understanding the industry
itself, but also the
implications that it has
and the ripple effects of
representation in media
in everything-- everyone on
this panel is talking about--
on immigration, on politics,
on the economy and leadership
roles in companies like Google,
the bamboo ceiling, everything.
There's such a wide diaspora
of Asian-Americans, 99%
of which never get represented.
And it's just beginning to have
a voice in mainstream media
and what the
dynamics of that are.
And now I'm working on writing
films and shows so that I
can contribute and continue
to talk in spaces like this
to help make those connections.
So for me, it's understanding
working in Hollywood,
also connecting that
to other industries
and other communities, because
this is much larger of an issue
and a much larger
strategy is necessary.
DAWN LEE TU: All right.
So how does diversity, you
know, or if you want to use
intersectionality, diaspora--
whatever your word is--
show up in your
everyday life, and how
does this impact your work?
RUSSELL JEUNG: Well,
I was going to say,
I think every
Asian-American and actually
every individual
here will experience
diversity in their families.
So I'm actually fifth,
sixth generation American.
And my family has gone through
exclusion, segregation,
a lot of the racial barriers
that a lot of people of color
face.
But even within my own
immediate family, I'm married--
I'm Chinese married to a Korean.
We have two foster daughters
who are refugees from Burma.
And then my extended family
are pretty multiracial.
And so I think everybody,
even if your family
was of the same
ethnicity, you know
you have generational divides,
you have gender divides.
And then when we go
out to eat, you're
not always eating Chinese
food and rice every day.
So I think we all experience
diversity in our relationships
and in our histories and in
just our day-to-day interactions
with people at our
workplace or at our schools.
So diversity is totally relevant
in our circumstances in the US.
DAWN LEE TU: Anybody
else want to jump in?
CHRISTINE MINJI CHANG: Did you
want me to talk about that now
or do you want me-- like, is
there another question when--
DAWN LEE TU: I know Minji
is dying to talk about--
CHRISTINE MINJI
CHANG: Well, I don't--
DAWN LEE TU: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRISTINE MINJI CHANG:
I'm curious-- well,
one of my examples of how I deal
with diversity in my day-to-day
life is that there's a
film coming out in August--
August 17, FYI-- called
"Crazy Rich Asians,"
and John Chu, who's
from the Bay, as am I,
he's directing it.
It's an ensemble
Asian-American--
it's Asian-- it's actually a
global Asian cast, half of whom
are Asian-American.
And recognizing as a
data point, if you will,
the fact that it's been
"Joy Luck Club," which
was 25 years ago, was the
last, like, mainstream
studio-backed ensemble
modern-day Asian-American
family that was on screen,
it's a big freaking deal
that it's been 25 years.
And the fact that
there's the show,
like, "Fresh Off The Boat"
and Dr. Ken, that there
are these blips on the radar
about diverse representation
of Asian-Americans that they
are so heavily weighted in terms
of the gravity of, like, this
is representing all Asians
when it's not.
I mean, everyone
here knows that there
are more than 46
ethnicities and cultures
and lang-- like,
way more languages.
But Asian includes so
many different people.
And yet people are writing these
individual shows with these
handful of actors to be,
like, the end-all-be-all
representatives of diversity.
That's a lot of pressure.
It's a lot of excitement,
because diversity suddenly
matters right now.
So for me, the way I'm
experiencing it is I'm
choosing to look
at the positive.
I'm choosing to look at these
are opportunities and gateways.
If this movie does
well, and it does matter
that this movie does well, as
controversial as some people
might be about this is
just Chinese people,
and this is just about
Chinese in Singapore,
did you read the book?
Like, that's what
the book's about.
And you cannot in one singular
movie define and represent all
of Asian-America.
But still, if this
film does well,
it does open up doors for
so many other projects
to get greenlit.
And Asians do have a
representation in Hollywood.
And whether this
is true or not--
you know, I don't
know if this is
an actual fact--
people will say,
like, Asians don't
support each other.
They don't watch
each other's shows.
If we make a show or
film about Asian people,
the numbers, like the
audience, doesn't reflect that.
Right?
So on a numbers and
business and industry basis,
diversity is in my
wheelhouse, in my life,
every single day in terms of
not just authentic storytelling
but the business
of the data points.
Who are the butts in the seats?
How are we showing up?
What kind of viewership
are we giving?
And what does that do for
everybody moving forward
in terms of getting
other projects--
other stories-- told?
DAWN LEE TU: Yeah.
Well, let's test that right now.
How many of you know "Crazy Rich
Asians" is going to come out?
OK.
Here's a real test.
How many of you actually
have it in your phone--
the day-- and
you're like already
organizing your friends?
Anybody?
OK, see--
CHRISTINE MINJI CHANG:
A viewing party.
DAWN LEE TU: OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
DAWN LEE TU: The point is,
like, representation matters.
Right?
CHRISTINE MINJI CHANG: Yeah.
DAWN LEE TU: I think
that's what you're saying.
CHRISTINE MINJI CHANG: For sure.
DAWN LEE TU: Yes.
Anything to add?
AIMEE PHAN: Well, I think
what's interesting is the--
I think the community support
is also really essential when
you're talking about if an
Asian-American movie comes out,
and I do understand the
instinct to critique
and to be concerned,
because there
has been so little
representation in the past
that anything that
comes out we're
so fearful of misrepresentation
and more misassumptions
and biases.
But that support
and that dialogue
is incredibly important
for it to be fostered
and to filter out
through the community.
I think the same applies
to the literature.
I think the same
applies to visual art
and to other forms of
communication and bringing
people together through art
to be able to articulate
our experiences.
And so that diversity
becomes pretty crucial.
And I agree.
Diversity happens--
like, the reason
why I started writing was I
looked around the dinner table
at my family and realized that
each of my aunt and uncles
and cousins and my mom and my
dad and my grandparents all
had a very unique migration
stories from Vietnam
to America, all of them.
They had very
different experiences.
And that's within
a family, right?
And so there has to be a
recognition and appreciation,
I think, of that
diversity and being
able to listen to each other
and foster that communication.
DAWN LEE TU: And yet, there
still is this tension,
right, this desire to recognize
specific and individual
experiences with the Asian and
Asian-American communities,
but then also we're
all this past month,
you all have been talking
about how do we come together?
How do we move forward together?
So what are some examples
in which you've seen--
and I'm thinking of you,
Anoop, in particular, right?
You've seen people
negotiate that tension
and find a way to build
coalitions and come together.
ANOOP PRASAD: So
storytelling is something
that's really important for
us at the Asian Law Caucus
and telling our client
stories, and we're always--
you know, we talk to thousands
and thousands of people
every month, right?
And the question always is,
like, which stories do we tell?
And so for us, part
of that is determining
who in our communities with all
this diversity has privilege.
Who has the spotlight?
Who has the microphone?
And who doesn't?
Right?
So we try to use the
privilege that we have,
the spotlight that
we have, to tell
stories that aren't being told.
And so the stories that do get
told, not just in Hollywood,
but also over social media
or sort of in our communities
leaves out a lot of people.
I often jokingly refer to
myself as Asian-asterisk, right,
because South Asians
are often left out
of the narrative of
who's considered Asian.
Pacific Islanders, we
say API, but really
no one really thinks about or
talks about Pacific Islanders
most of the time.
The experience of a lot of
Southeast Asian refugees
is also left out, and
you've got this very sort
of East-Asian-centric
narrative about who's Asian.
And so to some
degree, I think we
should think about
those things when
we're thinking about whose
stories are we telling.
The stories of South
Asians in culture,
it's the Quickie Mart owner, the
cab driver, and the terrorist.
Like, those are the three
representations we have.
There was this
Muslim ban happening,
but it's not really
considered an Asian issue.
So I think in some
degree when we
talk about building
these coalitions,
it's also important
to recognize who
in our really diverse
community has privilege
and to what degree can they
center these other stories that
are being buffed out and help
tell those stories instead
of occupying the spotlight
with their own stories.
DAWN LEE TU: So
Russell, when you're
teaching Asian-Americans, that
is, you're talking to students
about this tension as well, what
are some of the stories that
resonate with them about the
ways Asians and Asian-Americans
have come together
as a coalition
to be able to do things
like address injustice
or address, maybe not
even the bad things,
but just come
together in coalition.
What are the stories that
resonate with students?
RUSSELL JEUNG: Well, Aimee
was just involved in one.
One of our classes on
Vietnamese-American literature
did a poetry reading
around the Me Too Movement,
and we found that
over half our class
could relate to the issue of
domestic violence and abuse
on a personal one-degree
of separation level.
So there's a lot
of concrete issues
around which we can
build solidarity
that actually totally resonate
and that we can divide up
that issue as being a racialized
issue, as a gender issue.
And when people are able
to build, not only see
their own families affected,
but also develop that empathy
to build solidarity
with others, I
think that's how
my students move.
Hearing each other's
stories, both
knowing the individual
uniqueness of that story,
but making those
connections with others
and seeing how race,
how transnationalism,
how capitalism have shaped
these experiences to be similar
and how we have a common sort of
target of fighting or resisting
the suppression, I think
that's what mobilizes them.
DAWN LEE TU: And
Aimee, how do you
think about the
representation and then
also which stories
to tell as you're
thinking about the stories
that you yourself are writing
and what you want to
share with the audiences?
AIMEE PHAN: Well, my
mother was a social worker,
and she worked with
a lot of children
who came over as boat refugees.
And she would work
on these case files,
and it was really
important for her
to express to her children
to understand the privilege
that we came from, the fact that
we came over in the first wave,
and that we had an education.
We had opportunities that other
refugees and immigrants did not
have.
And so she was always--
she wasn't a creative
writer, but she would always
be sharing these
stories in order,
like I said, to increase
my compassion and empathy
and gratitude as well.
Like, you need to be
grateful, and what are you
going to do with the
opportunities that you have?
And what stories can you tell?
And so I think a
very huge reason
why I wanted to become a
writer was I wasn't reading--
at the time, there were no
Vietnamese-American books.
There were very few
Asian-American books.
The ones you had are
burned in my memories.
I still remember
"Farewell to Manzanar."
I remember "No-No Boy."
I remember the very few
books on my bookshelf
that actually
reflected my experience
and what it felt like to be
someone in a predominantly
white environment.
And when a child especially
recognizes him or herself
in a book, it is a validation.
It's a self-validation
that empowers them.
And I think that is something
that literature and art can do.
And so that's why seeking out
those stories, understanding
them, like I said, like
with Me Too Movement,
it was part of a collective
called She Who Has No Masters.
It's a collective of Vietnamese
women writers and gender
non-conforming writers.
And we wanted to
talk about Me Too,
and we called it Me
Too, Vietnamese Bodies.
What are the stories
that aren't being told?
Right?
Because the Me Too Movement
is rooted in social media
and not-- and there
are many people
who are not on social media.
How do we collect these stories?
How do we eliminate
a lot of that shame?
And it's about listening.
It's about listening and
then conveying these stories
and talking with each other.
TU: I know for me, coming
to understand and appreciate
my own identity as a
Chinese-American in relation
to my broader political identity
as an Asian-American was
definitely a process, to
be able to see myself,
and then to be able to see
myself as part of a community.
What was that like
for some of you
to understand the
sense of self-identity
in connection to this
broader identity?
What is something that
you want to share?
AIMEE PHAN: I think it
happened, for me at least, late,
and I think it might have been
just because the time period.
I see it happening earlier
from my own children.
My daughter, who
is nine, strongly
identifies as a
Vietnamese-American--
as a half Vietnamese-American.
For me, growing up with a lot
of white people around me,
I didn't feel proud until
college, which is late,
but it was incredibly
liberating when
it happened, because
that was when
I started taking the classes.
That's when the Vietnam
War was a taboo word.
That's when there were classes
on issues, and histories,
and literature that were about
the people who looked like me.
And now I feel there are
more ethnic studies classes
happening earlier in education.
There are more
cultural opportunities.
The Vietnamese
community has been
here for longer, so we have--
and now as the younger
generation is teaching
the children, and so there
are more opportunities when
they're young.
But for me it didn't
happen until college.
ANOOP PRASAD: So I grew up in
the deep south, in New Orleans,
and I grew up in a black
and Vietnamese neighborhood
with very few
South Asian people.
And so I think I learned
early on that I'm not white,
but in terms of
an Asian identity,
it wasn't exactly clear.
I mean, there were way
more Vietnamese people
than South Asian people
in my neighborhood.
But I think I definitely learned
about race in a much different
way than it is in California.
I very definitely
learned about it
in terms of this black-white
binary that existed,
and which side of
the line I was on.
And so I'm still,
I think, getting
used to being in California.
I'm looking around the room,
I'm like, this does not really
exist.
And say I work at Oregon, and
it was 30-something people,
and it's amazing radical
Asian lawyers there,
but it's still mind-boggling
sometimes where I am,
and it's easy to forget
here that Asians are only
like 5% of the country.
RUSSELL JEUNG: I grew
up in San Francisco.
So it was easy
growing up in, like,
if you're in an ethnic
enclave of, you know,
90% Asian-Americans, it's
pretty easy to develop
an Asian-American consciousness,
and to see the pan-ethnic
commonalities--
our generational--
it was really easy,
because we were all
dressing alike, listening
to the same type
of music, playing
the same kind of sports,
going to the same clubs.
So that was-- it became
a subculture that
shifted to a political
identity as I began to see,
yeah, I'm privileged in
some ways as a middle class
Asian-American, but there
are other Asian-Americans who
are suffering a lot
more-- people in Chinatown
aren't getting
their wages, and I
need to support-- give
them my privilege.
CHRISTINE MINJI: I grew up
in Cupertino during the '90s.
And if anyone was growing up
in South Bay in the Bay Area,
or LA during the
'90s, if you guys
remember, like, the
Asian pride era.
RUSSELL JEUNG: AZN.
CHRISTINE MINJI: AZN pride--
special times-- that's actually
what my first film is about.
But that was definitely
the post-riots--
all these academic
things about the culture
that I didn't know
until really recently.
I just experienced
that, and road AZN pride
on all my stuff, my screen name,
Xanga, AIM, all that stuff.
So I was very immersed in
that Asian pride culture--
that subculture,
but I didn't realize
until I moved to Pleasanton--
that was special.
Well it's different now,
but at the time when
I moved it was still
like 97%, 98% white,
at the time that I
moved in the '90s.
And it was a very stark
realization of being othered.
And it wasn't
hostile or negative,
but I was definitely
singled out,
and they assigned me to
the other Asian girl.
You should be
friends with Annie.
And I was like, oh, OK.
And I went with it.
I was like, that's
my Asian sister.
She is my friend.
It was an automatic connection.
So it was markers like that
that made me very aware,
and in a way very prideful,
about being Korean-American,
being Asian-American.
But then navigating that and
coming to terms with it really
happened, again, more towards
the end of high school
and college, where there are
cultural organizations where
we're talking more.
But even in college I feel
like the conversations were not
nearly as sophisticated as now.
We did not have the
word intersectionality.
I ran the Korean-American
student organization.
We did community
service and we partied.
We didn't talk that
much about identity.
We didn't really dig into
what those dynamics were.
We put on culture
shows as a celebration,
but we wouldn't
really go in depth.
So I feel like it's been
a very ongoing process,
and then joining
Collaboration, and starting
the Bay Area chapter
in 2009 was definitely
an eye-opening
experience to the wider
diversity of Asian America.
And I'm continually--
I feel like now I'm
going through
Asian-American studies.
I wasn't interested in
taking those courses
when I went to Cal.
And they were available for
me, I just wasn't interested,
which is bizarre.
DAWN LEE TU: That's OK.
We won't tell your teachers.
CHRISTINE MINJI: Yeah,
please don't tell them.
[LAUGHTER]
DAWN LEE TU: So Minji, you
started touching on, I think,
how things have changed
for you over time, right.
So I want to reflect
a little bit on that,
and think about
what is our future.
What does our
community's future look
like in terms of the diversity,
the identities, and our ability
to-- what are we working on
in terms of coming together?
So what do you all think
is in our future for Asians
and Asian-Americans?
[INAUDIBLE] it
was collaboration,
because you probably see--
I mean, you've seen so much,
and to a certain extent,
the work that you've
done in collaboration
is also very future-facing.
CHRISTINE MINJI: Absolutely.
I've been educated
more through the people
I've met through
collaboration, because it
was across North America,
including Canada,
and understanding how different
my upbringing in the Bay Area--
my privileged and very
diverse upbringing in the Bay
is very different than
Detroit, Michigan,
different than Atlanta, Georgia,
different than Washington, DC.
And so that has been alone
just its own education.
But what I see in my
peers, in the people who
support us, and the
younger generation,
because of social media, because
of YouTube, changed the game.
There is more
conversation happening
at a much more rapid pace
that's more sophisticated, more
nuanced, and therefore I
think more just motivational
for young kids to learn who
they are, love who they are,
and just go out and
make amazing things.
They don't have the same
level of self-consciousness
or the same self-limitations
that we've all
had to navigate for
different reasons,
whether it be our
geographical location,
or the way our
parents raised us.
I inherited my 1980 version
of Korea from my parents.
You know what I mean?
I didn't grow up with
the current Korea.
I go there, and I feel
very much othered there,
as much as I'm Korean-American.
So we have these very unique
stories, and I'm just--
the coalitions are real.
You know, the South Asian
community, everybody---
I honestly think this
political climate, as awful
as it is, it is a blessing in
disguise to get people to care
and to move.
So they're saying,
OK, fine, with
this collectively marginalized
community, what we have to do?
And that's creating
a lot of urgency
to put aside whatever
competitive agendas and all
that.
And there is a lot more unity--
a lot more strategy I feel
like, because now there's
the shared goal of, if we
don't speak up for ourselves,
if we don't make it a priority
to fund, get films greenlit, to
make sure to create programs--
all the major studios have
diversity programs now.
This did not exist.
So this creates opportunities
for me as an actor
that I didn't have, that it
was a different playing field
five, 10 years ago,
and now they're
creating diversity programs
where they're seeking out
everyone of color,
LGBTQ, millennials.
They're trying to get
different voices in there
on purpose because people
are getting pissed off enough
and inspired enough
to say, we want
to see our
communities on screen.
You can't whitewash us
out of our own stories
and think we're going to
sit peacefully by and watch
this nonsense, you
know what I mean.
So I credit social media.
That's why I'm so proud
to be from the Bay,
and to have had my
roots in Silicon Valley,
because things that are
happening in this place
are changing the entire world.
So I look to that, and
that is the future,
in technology and all the
platforms that are emerging.
You are not relegated
to, like, five studios
running all of media.
You have a lot more
voices, and people are
getting scared, which is good.
[LAUGHTER]
Keep them on their toes.
DAWN LEE TU: Go ahead
and jump in, Russell.
RUSSELL JEUNG: Yeah,
can I bounce off that?
So we have more platforms.
We have more opportunities
to create a voice.
I think emerging
Asian-Americans will become
the creative class of America.
If you look in academia
today-- if you look even
in the world of
literature and arts,
there's a lot of Asian-Americans
going into it because
of selective immigration.
Those coming in today are
educated professionals,
and their kids are becoming
the creative class.
So the creative
class are those who
create culture, who create
the discourses by which we
sort of understand the world.
The danger, though, of
Asian-Americans becoming
the creative class and--
as I see this--
sorry to jump on
Millennials is that--
CHRISTINE MINJI:
Please, go ahead.
RUSSELL JEUNG: We've all
become digital prisoners.
DAWN LEE TU: It's OK.
There's Q&A afterward.
[LAUGHTER]
RUSSELL JEUNG: Everyone's sort
of trapped on their own phones,
and we've become
hyper-individualized,
and so that makes mobilizing on
a collective scales a lot more
difficult. It's easier
to do social movements
through social
media, but it also
divides and conquers
us to be markets
rather than communities.
And so as we become
the creative class,
I think we could redefine what
it means to be Asian-American.
Nobody thinks of
Asian-Americans with a history
of justice necessarily, or
an an ethic of compassion.
But as we develop into
this creative class,
and as long as we can
build those commonalities
and solidarities,
and that empathy,
and start working
not just on behalf
of our own
self-interest, but out
of the concerns for
low-income people
or for other
marginalized groups,
then we can actually
have possibilities
to create our identity
that we want it to be.
You know, Asian-Americans
being a just people,
Asian-Americans being
a people of equity.
So for me that's the hope,
that the term and the grouping
of Asian-American has all
this unforeseen possibility.
And people here
are the people who
are sort of filling
in the gaps of what
it means to be Asian-American.
And so it's both exciting,
but we're also a little bit
too imprisoned by our phones.
DAWN LEE TU: Yeah.
Go ahead, Anoop.
ANOOP PRASAD: So I think
we're at a place of crisis
and a turning point right
now about whether or not
we take that plunge
towards being
a community about justice.
So we're the
fastest-growing community
of color in the country,
even though we're still only,
I think, five and
a half percent.
And I think the country is in
this state of crisis right now.
There's a war happening
over white supremacy, which
has been happening this
country for centuries,
but right now it's
out in the open.
And so I think the
Asian community
is at this place where it
needs to pick its sides.
And for a really long
time, and by intention,
we've been used as a weapon
against black people,
and against people of color.
Our immigration
system is set up so
that it's only educated
Asians that are allowed
to easily come to the US.
And so we were always
held up by white supremacy
as the good immigrants.
We come here legally.
We're not like our Latino
friends that cross the border.
Were held up against black
people as, oh, you know,
they're people of color but
they have really high graduation
rates, and their incarceration
rates aren't high.
Why can't black people
be like Asians, right.
And that started almost
immediately after the Civil
Rights movement,
was that we were
pitted against other
communities of color.
And to a large degree, a lot
of our communities at times
have played into that.
Sometimes that's
survival, of, we're
going to try and be respectable,
and be the good immigrants,
and it will get us as close
to whiteness as we can.
There's this hierarchy where
we're never quite going
to have the rights
of white people,
but maybe it will get us close.
And I think there is this
decision by some communities
at certain times to
go along with that,
because they needed to survive
as immigrants in this country.
But in the end it's
becoming clearer and clearer
that that isn't
going to protect us.
The Muslim ban doesn't care
if you're respectable or not.
It doesn't care
if you have a PhD.
It doesn't matter.
So I think we're
at this juncture
of we need to decide
about whether we're
going to be silenced
by white supremacy,
quietly sort of play
into the respectability,
or cast our lot with other
communities of color.
And I think there's
a narrow window
that we now have as a community
in making these decisions.
DAWN LEE TU: Yeah.
Aimee?
AIMEE PHAN: I am very aware
that any success I have is
due to community organizations.
The organizations I
credited to become a writer
are the Asian-American
Journal Association,
the Diaspora of Vietnamese
Artists Network,
and Asian-American
studies departments
around the country that
help support my writing,
and help support my book.
And so it was
always built into me
that if it wasn't for these
people who had been successful,
and were looking to cultivate
the younger generations,
I wouldn't have what I had.
And so I think that made
me much more appreciative
of how important community
organizations are
in terms of influencing
generations and allyship.
And that certainly applies to
this current political climate.
And I realize that
sometimes social media can
feel like a bubble, like you're
only talking to the people who
are like you, but I do see,
since the election, more
political activism,
and how we're going
to use the resources we have.
What superpowers do we have
to fight against the things
that we're really
concerned about?
And so I see graphic novelists
drawing and depicting
cases of undocumented
immigrants.
I see more writing, I see more
editorials, I see more art,
and these are
fostering conversations
and helping create dialogues
so that that threat--
especially for
Asian-American communities
to look inward and
only protect themselves
can't necessarily
happen anymore.
And I think
constantly reminding--
and being reminded of the
fact that this happened
to us just 40 years ago--
just a little over
40 years ago, where
everything was taken away.
It can happen to any of us.
So what are we going to do?
How are we going
to help each other?
And I think reminding
ourselves about that allyship
and community
space is important.
DAWN LEE TU: Thank you so much.
I think between actually
calling us into this discussion
about where are we going to
stand, what are we going to do,
and how are we going to come
together, I think each of you
in your own way
talked about that.
All right.
So it's your turn now.
We've heard such rich
conversation up here.
I want to make sure that
you all have an opportunity
to ask questions, to engage
with the panelists as well.
If you have a question,
please step up.
There's a mic right here,
right in front of me.
Please do that so that we can
get you on and we can hear you.
Come on up.
CHRISTINE MINJI: [INAUDIBLE]
DAWN LEE TU: I didn't
pre-set any questions,
so I don't have any plants
in the audience, so--
yeah.
OK, we have a
question right here.
Come on up.
AUDIENCE: My name is Grace Yu.
Professor Jeung
had some thoughts.
You know, he had thought the
phone was making our generation
hyper-individualized, and that
we needed to move forward,
and that Asian-Americans
hopefully would
be sort of this just community.
So granted that phones
aren't going to go away,
I had a question for
you, Professor Jeung.
How can we use the phone--
I mean, Aimee, you suggested
that the phone, in some sense,
has sort of galvanized
and organized folks.
So I guess the question,
maybe for everybody,
is how can we use technology--
it's not going to go away
anytime soon, and people
will have their phones--
how can we use
technology in a way that
brings together community,
and moves our community along
towards justice?
DAWN LEE TU: Great question.
Who wants to jump in?
ANOOP PRASAD: So in my work
we actually use social media
quite a bit to organize.
And it's not by itself.
There's also
organizing happening
on the ground in
communities, but social media
is really critical for a
lot of the advocacy we do.
I mean, I remember,
Muslim ban 1.0,
that first weekend where
it got signed Friday night,
and we started working
that very night,
and then I was blown away
by the number of people
that we were able to
mobilize, and we've not
been able to do that
without the internet.
Our standard way of
mobilizing for an action
is flyers, and word of
mouth, and that would not
have turned out
thousands of people
at every airport in the
country within a few hours.
Often we run
anti-deportation campaigns,
and you were mentioning
artists are really
stepping up, and helping
tell stories through artwork.
[INAUDIBLE] who's a really
amazing graphic novelist,
has been helping us with a
lot of our anti-deportation
campaigns, and making artwork
for online petitions, which
have an enormous
amount of impact
in getting people
free from detention,
and also telling their stories.
We use it to pass legislation,
we do call-in actions--
all using social media--
using Facebook and Twitter.
Sorry to plug
Google's competitors.
[LAUGHTER]
But it is really a critical
part of our work now.
DAWN LEE TU: What
are you seeing,
Minji, in terms of the
innovative ways performing
artists are using technology?
CHRISTINE MINJI: I think it's
been happening organically.
And with being in a
generation that has grown up
in a lot of our formative years,
and then with a new generation
where they just are born
out the womb knowing how
to, like, hashtag, people
get savvier by the day.
And I think YouTube itself--
Asian America, period-- everyone
credits YouTube for changing
Asian America, because
the YouTubers--
there is a specific generation
specifically between 2006
and 2012--
the content creators, because we
were not inundated with content
at that point and they
were still early adopters,
these celebrities that emerged
out of that YouTube generation
still make a living
off of that today.
It created a gateway
for Asian-Americans
to influence a whole other
generation of younger
Asian-Americans
to see themselves,
because there's a
lot of kids out there
who will look at
YouTube as a bigger
deal than network television.
They can identify
their YouTube stars.
They can't identify Jimmy
Fallon, or whoever, right.
And so it's just
really interesting,
because that gave
people confidence,
and it makes that ripple effect.
I really believe in
the power of art--
like a book, a song, or a skit.
It's so random,
but it really gives
a kid or an older person--
whoever watches it,
they're like, oh, they get me.
They get my story.
Oh, and then they start
messaging each other.
They share it.
The sharing of videos, and
there's tweeting and all that,
it has massive ripple effects.
You don't know what kinds
of seeds that plants.
And so I think the internet's
incredibly powerful.
It can galvanize people.
It motivates people.
It pisses people off,
because they're like,
oh, you made that skit.
That was funny, but it was at
the expense of these people.
I've seen these
conversations happen
where young Asian-American kids
would kind of make a gay joke,
and then that would cause a
whole conversation about issues
within the
Asian-American community
about not acknowledging
the LGBTQ community.
And so then someone will go
out and make their own skit to,
like--
that's kind of the
age that we live in.
There's tons of
content out there,
but I think that that's
what needs to happen.
It's not just theory
and our thoughts.
We've got to do, we've got
to say, we've got to speak,
and that's what's going to
keep maturing the conversation.
That's what's going to make
content creators get better
at what they do.
I can sit here and
say, I'm a writer.
But if I never put words
on a piece of paper--
type it out, I'll
never get better.
And I think that's a lot of
the things that I've seen
in Asian-America is
that self-limitation,
this fear of rocking the
boat, this fear of shaming
our families--
I can't air my
family's dirty laundry.
Because all our stories are
so personal and very deep.
But if we don't do
that, then we're
just going to stay invisible.
You know what I mean?
So if you're a generation of
kids, and you can actually say,
I don't like the Scarlett
Johanson casting.
That's great.
The world needs to know that.
And then "Hollywood Reporter"
can write an editorial
on that about the problematic
nature of whitewashing.
And they'll bring
up Mickey Rooney.
They'll bring up everything--
you know, Bruce Lee
included-- everything,
and then we can start
having those conversations.
So sharing-- I believe in
every individual in here,
just because you're not
an actor, or a writer,
or a CEO, or
producer, or whatever,
everyone through the
power of their phone,
has the power of influence.
Somebody is looking
at that data.
Somebody is making
decisions based off of that,
like viewership.
There are artists that
are independent that
make their living off
of YouTube viewership
and get hired to
speak at colleges,
or do a little music tour.
They make their
living off of that.
So those views, I know
for a fact, count so much.
So don't ever take
yourself out of the running
of your own influence.
DAWN LEE TU: Russell, Aimee,
some quick last thoughts.
RUSSELL JEUNG: Yeah, I
have a lot of thoughts.
Technology isn't necessarily
organic in the development.
It's capitalized,
and it's funded,
and people are making
money off of technology.
And I would argue
that technology
has become the
opiate of the masses,
that Asian-Americans
are so concerned
about their representation,
and how they are seen,
and whether we're invisible--
invisible to whom?
I see my family every day.
I see them.
I know them.
I know them by name.
They are not invisible to me.
I know their story.
They don't have to
tell me their story.
They're not voiceless.
We're so concerned
about representation,
but we're not concerned
about real people living
in real conditions.
So it's both/and that
our representations
affect how we care about people
and their material conditions.
Are they poor?
Do they have health care access?
Can they speak to a
doctor in their language?
So I'm sort of concerned
for Asian-Americans
who are so concerned
about representation,
they got to get
outside of technology
and start dealing with real
people in real situations,
and develop a sense of
compassion and heart.
So it's not just
about telling a story.
It's about alleviating the
injustices and the poverty,
and the struggles that a lot
of people are going through.
Now a lot of Asian-Americans
who look like you and me
if you're Asian-American--
it could be like
your grandparents
--are going through
really hard difficulties.
And if all we care
about is representation,
I think it's just
like, oh, I'm going
to just watch another
YouTube video to de-stress.
Social media is
causing Asian-Americans
to have higher rates of
anxiety and depression
now in this generation
than ever before.
So it has its good things,
but we have to be aware--
CHRISTINE MINJI: But that's
also residual from actual Asia.
I mean, Koreans have
the highest rate
of suicide in the
world, and alcoholism,
and plastic surgery.
And that's a documentary I would
like to make, to talk about it.
They don't want to
talk about it, though.
So I completely--
[LAUGHTER]
I'm learning so much.
I really want to talk to you.
[LAUGHTER]
And this is great,
though, because I
feel like there's just this
difference, because the people
that I'm around-- the artists
that I'm around particularly,
they care about
everything about that.
So there's always
going to be pockets,
a range of people who care--
I'm just a beauty blogger.
Just send me all the
sponsored products,
and that's all they care about.
Fine, but they
have influence when
they start talking about
body image, and anxiety,
and dysmorphia, anorexia,
eating disorders, whatever.
And then you can have the
people who are very social
justice-minded,
because when they
see that only the things
that people are talking about
are things about looking pretty
and your Instagram filter,
it's going to cause a rise
out of people who are like,
what about refugees?
What about poverty?
And they'll get motivated to
make those stories shine, too.
DAWN LEE TU: I mean,
there's tensions, right?
Aimee, you have the last word.
AIMEE PHAN: Well, I think it's
the content in the social media
that is making us anxious.
There is a lot of
noise, but I think
people can also become
really good about listening
to what's important.
A lot of those stories, we
wouldn't know about them
if they weren't on social media.
And I do think the reason why
representation is important,
it becomes a gateway.
Those stories are
important for us to feel.
Most people, they are
motivated by their emotions
rather than by facts.
I didn't really understand--
or I didn't really
feel the impact of so
many historical events
until I read about it, about
even fictional characters
experiencing that emotion,
going through these feelings
of shame, or anger, or
frustration, or alienation.
And that is how we create
compassion with other people,
and that's how other
people learn our stories,
and then they try to
make a difference.
But if we don't have
those stories available,
then we're not going
to have people curious
to be able to hear more, and
listen, and pay attention
to the very real
issues of the fact
that there is an incredible
diversity in Asian-Americans,
and that we have
the opportunities
to help each other,
to help all income
levels of Asian-Americans, and
see where we're coming from,
and where we're supposed to go.
DAWN LEE TU: Well I want
to thank each of you,
Aimee, Anoop, Russell, Minji,
for contributing to a really,
really rich conversation.
Can we say thank you to them?
[APPLAUSE]